[Música]
hace 4 años yo no sabía que se podía
utilizar la fuerza empresarial para ser
agente de cambio
hoy vengo a contarles cómo a partir de
descubrir el frío descubrí que quería
ayudar a los niños a no sentirlo
mis hermanos y yo además descubrimos que
utilizaríamos nuestra energía para crear
una marca que le ayudará a las personas
a consumir de manera responsable y
consecuente
yo estoy seguro que aquí todos ustedes
saben lo que es tener frío pero hace
cinco años mis hermanos y yo viajamos a
una comunidad en cusco y sentimos el
frío de primera mano
pero este frío que viene acompañado con
la enorme cantidad de necesidades que
tienen los niños que crecen en situación
de vulnerabilidad en los andes peruanos
ojo que no era temporada de la 2
las heladas son este fenómeno
climatológico que ocurre normalmente
entre los meses de mayo y agosto en el
que ingresan vientos helados del sur
generando temperaturas de hasta menos 20
grados en algunas comunidades en la
sierra centro y sur del perú
nosotros estábamos preparados para el
frío pero así con todo nos moríamos el
frío yo no pude evitar de preguntarle
una niña si no tenía frío y me dijo
señor aquí entre las 5 de la tarde y las
8 de la mañana todos los días del año es
invierno y es que es verdad no porque
cuando llega el invierno todos nos
volvemos solidarios empezamos a donar
nuestra ropa nuestras mantas pero hasta
que llegue el verano sale el sol nos
ponemos ropa de baño y nos vamos a la
playa nos olvidamos pero ya arriba el
frío seguiré simplemente como siempre y
si bien no estará a menos 20 grados 5
grados igual es recontra frío
ahí mismo decidimos que lo que queríamos
hacer era ayudar a mejorar la calidad de
vida de los niños
no sabíamos exactamente qué íbamos a
hacer pero sabíamos que lo haríamos
desde nuestro metro cuadrado habíamos
decidido ser agentes de cambio
empezamos a investigar un poco y
descubrimos que en el perú hay más de 5
millones de personas que viven por
encima de los 3000 metros y se ven
afectadas por las heladas de una u otra
manera todos los años y que entre ellos
hay más de 1.5 millones de niños entre 1
y 12 años
un tiempo después mi esposa a quien le
debo muchísimo lo que soy me regaló un
libro sobre toms un emprendimiento que
estaba revolucionando la manera de
consumir
la historia era simple y estaba siendo
contada por su propio fundador y la
verdad que a mí no me llamó tanto la
atención sus productos pero algo se me
quedó grabado by one won compra uno dona
uno
por cada alpargata que esta marca vendía
le entregaba a otra a un niño en
necesidad
alucinante era un dos por uno solidario
entonces esa idea se me quedó en la
cabeza dando vueltas y vueltas y un día
en mi trabajo y otras como director de
cine publicitario mucho tiempo y estaba
editando un vídeo un vídeo que no tenía
nada que ver ni con los niños y con el
frío ni con los andes de pronto en la
sala todo empezó a perder sentido y las
voces empezaron a sonar como un guau
y es que una idea se estaba formando en
mi cabeza hice una pausa y decidí ahí
mismo que lo que quería hacer en una
marca de ropa que por cada prenda de
abrigo que vendiera entregaría otra a un
niño en necesidad compra uno dona uno
salí corriendo de la isla de edición y
llamé a mi hermano patrick eres el más
racional de los tres y de verdad es un
poco pincharlo
y yo no podía creerlo que después de
contarles la idea no solamente le había
gustado sino que realmente quería que le
hiciéramos ahí el toque ya me ahí a mi
otro hermano y se subió el toque del
coche
mis papás nos criaron bajo el principio
de ser empáticos entonces tener la
capacidad de ponernos en los zapatos de
los demás se convirtió casi una manera
de vivir para nosotros otra cosa que nos
enseñaron es a que nunca debíamos bajar
los brazos y que siempre que contaríamos
el uno por el otro
yo me considero una persona recontra
afortunada de verdad soy un lechero
tengo una familia increíble biológica y
política una esposa maravillosa unos
hijos hermosos unos hermanos que además
son mis mejores amigos entonces
emprender algo con ellos era de verdad
como un sueño
pero de lo que yo realmente me siento
afortunado es de haber nacido donde nací
porque eso me ha dado a mí una enorme
cantidad de oportunidades una educación
de primera
'amigos de lujo contactos viajes y la
verdad que para nacer uno como que no
hace mucho no
mi mamá se la pasó 18 horas sufriendo yo
ya
y en el perú muchísimas personas
simplemente por no haber nacido donde yo
nací no cuentan con esas oportunidades
entonces hacer algo por ellos aunque
fuera algo pequeño era como que algo
justo no para nosotros
yo realmente creo que no tiene nada de
malo tener suerte yo creo que más bien
reconocer que uno tiene suerte y no
hacer nada algo con ella eso sí me
parece que está mal
así así comienza a jose
una marca que nace con el propósito de
abrir a los niños nosotros sabemos que
no podemos acabar con el frío pero lo
que sí sabemos es que podemos ayudarlos
a que estén más preparados para ese
contexto porque ojo el frío solamente
feo cuando uno no está preparado
esa fue la motivación suficiente para
hacerla y así nos lanzamos teníamos una
idea un idea que se la recontra chévere
pero teníamos que encontrar una forma de
que esta idea fuera rentable por
escalable así decidimos hacer una
empresa porque creemos en la fuerza
empresarial y su capacidad de generar
cambios en la sociedad con un doble
efecto
por un lado generan empleo pero por el
otro lado generan nuevos hábitos de
consumo que le ayuda a las personas
tomar mejores decisiones nosotros por
ejemplo en jose no queremos que la gente
se compre una casaca para abrigarse allá
nosotros queremos que la gente se compre
una casaca para abrigarse y que al mismo
tiempo nos estén ayudando a brillar a
otro niño
así decidimos empezar por el impacto y
nos propusimos abrir a la comunidad en
cusco ahí donde la niña nos abre nos
habló de ese invierno este permanente de
los andes' aprendimos muchísimo ese
proceso porque nosotros no queríamos
romper la armonía y atentar contra las
costumbres de la comunidad diseñamos
entonces nuestro primer producto la
casaca solidaria
sabíamos que tenía que ser funcional no
era necesario que fuera impermeable pero
sí resistente al agua para que pudieran
rápidamente ponerse en un cobijo y estar
secos
utilizar un material para que fuera
acortamiento será muy importante pero
también incluir un cuello alto y
elásticos en los puños para que el
viento no entre
decidimos usar un de polar porque
no solo es caliente sino que además es
rico y suave al tacto
finalmente le incluimos un relleno de
fibra que lo que busca es generar calor
pero quizás lo más importante que
descubrimos es que nosotros debíamos ser
simplemente una capa más que no había la
necesidad de llevarles una casaca super
gruesa porque imagínense pedirle un niño
que tiene poco que se quite lo poco que
tiene para ponerse una casaca no no
funciona es más nosotros lo que queremos
hacer es la penúltima capa así la última
pueden ser sus ponchos y sus trajes
típicos y esa es la razón por la cual
nuestras casas solidarias son rojas
porque están inspiradas en la cochinilla
un insumo utilizado en los andes' para
teñir sus trajes típicos de esta manera
nuestra casaca conviviría en armonía
para empezar teníamos que pedir un
préstamo decidimos pedir un préstamo
personal con esas maravillosas tasas a
girar los bancos
y lo pagamos entre los tres decidimos
con parte de ese dinero habría a 300
niños de las quebradas de puma huanca
iguarán en busca
ambas comunidades quedan en la
cordillera del urubamba y para llegar a
ellas uno debe caminar por un camino
inca increíble
y es verdad que uno aprende muchísimo en
las entregas uno se lleva mucho más de
lo que deja
pero lo más bonito fue en esas primeras
entregas ver los rostros de los niños y
de sus padres cuando entregamos las
casacas ahí sabíamos que estábamos
frente a un proyecto muy lindo y que
había que lanzarse con todo
luego tuvimos que diseñar unos hechos
pues había que vender
lo diseñamos entre los tres y logramos
plasmar en ellos los conceptos de la
marca spring ones nuestra promesa la de
esparcir el calor que responde a la voz
de la marca y la importancia que para
nosotros tiene el calor humano por eso
en cada una de las mangas llevamos una
de las palabras así cuando abrazamos se
forma la frase
decidimos usar dos colores uno a cada
lado
el rojo representaba el calor y lo
llevamos igual que el logo en el lado
izquierdo dónde está nuestro corazón
el celeste representa el frío y es un
recordatorio de que aún hay más niños
por abrir
las ventas principalmente se dieron
entre amigos y familias pues como es
lógico en un emprendimiento pero
llegamos a algunas personas a través del
boca a boca y una de ellas salvador nos
ayudó muchísimo
trabajo con patrick en un plan y un
modelo de negocio se convirtió en socio
luego un cofundador y finalmente nos
ayudó a levantar los primeros fondos
para que pudiéramos dar el segundo paso
con la marca
así volando pasaron dos años y lanzamos
nuestra primera colección casacas
chalecos switchers polos gorras medias
suyos el proceso de diseño fue todo un
desafío no había diseñador en la empresa
y decidimos diseñar nuestra confeccionar
nuestras casas en oriente principalmente
por un tema de know-how pero es muy
bueno en textiles pero de verdad créanme
no es casa pero por lo menos no estoy
para trabajar con oriente uno debería
trabajar en las madrugadas yo recuerdo
un día que estábamos viendo el fit de la
casaca que es súper importante y de
pronto me preguntaron sobre la sisa
las sisas resulta que es un corto que se
le hace la tela abajo de la axila pero
me veían a mí a las dos de la mañana
realizando en google que coser a la sisa
para poder responder
no fue nada fácil además porque tuvimos
que negociar con los posibles puntos de
venta y no tiene idea cómo rebotaba
porque no entendían el concepto
no es nada fácil hacer una marca más aún
cuando uno tiene recursos limitados y
cuando lo que uno ofrece es más un
concepto que un producto
en toda esta locura de estar
pretendiendo crear esta marca y este
proyecto apareció un documental un
documental que nos cambió el rumbo un
documental que evidenciaba a la
industria textil como una emergencia
ambiental
sabían por ejemplo ustedes que el 20 por
ciento de todo el agua contaminada del
planeta
proviene de la industria textil
o que entre el 2000 y el 2016 se
duplicaron la cantidad de prendas
confeccionadas pero bajó a la mitad la
vida útil de ellos
era como un hada al corazón pues
estábamos ahí queriendo ser una empresa
que ayude a mejorar la calidad de vida
de los niños
y nos estábamos metiendo en una
industria que había sido catalogada como
una emergencia ambiental por las
naciones unidas'
y los tres nos sentamos a discutir y a
ver qué hacíamos y decidimos que
nosotros no queríamos abrir a los niños
cueste lo que cueste nosotros queríamos
hacer las cosas con responsabilidad y
nos dimos cuenta que nuestra colección
de ropa generaría un impacto negativo y
si lo que nosotros queremos es construir
una marca que lo que busca es generar
impacto positivo teníamos que tomar
algunas decisiones y así tomamos 3
la primera fue que nos buscamos una
certificación en el 2016 logramos
certificarnos como una empresa ve las
empresas ve son empresas con propósitos
que lo que buscan es redefinir la
economía trabajando con el chip el botón
line donde las personas el planeta y las
ganancias convivan en equilibrio
esta certificación nos abrió los ojos
empezamos a analizar los insumos que
teníamos y decidimos incluir algunos
productos en nuestras colecciones por
ejemplo como el algodón orgánico o la
alpaca
el argón orgánico es un insumo que le
beneficia a la salud y al medio ambiente
porque es un producto cultivado en
tierras fértiles libres de pesticidas
insecticidas la albahaca además de sus
propiedades térmicas y de brillo y de
caída
está libre de crueldad animal
empezamos entonces a también buscar
certificaciones para algunos insumos
como el down pass para nuestras plumas
que certifica su calidad y su
trazabilidad y nos asegura de que no es
un insumo que proviene de un animal vivo
empezamos a utilizar telas de plástico
reciclado tanto para casas de adultos
como de niños inclusive logramos incluir
un insumo en la casaca solidaria hecho a
base de botellas de plástico recicladas
el relleno sintético y así cada casaca
solidaria reciclados botellas plásticas
de 2 litros
luego decidimos mejorar nuestro impacto
y así tomamos la decisión de
confeccionar todas las casacas
solidarias en el penal de ancón 2 por
los internos un proyecto muy lindo que
no solo busca darle trabajo digno a los
internos sino que en algunos casos
inclusive un oficio
pero lo más bacán de ese programa es que
son los clientes los que hacen posible
que una comunidad en situación de
vulnerabilidad como son los internos
esté ayudando a otra comunidad en
situación de vulnerabilidad como son los
niños en los antes
hoy estamos trabajando en más productos
para mantener este programa y seguir
dándoles trabajo
y lo último que hicimos fue que todos
nuestros pueblos y accesorios sembrarían
un árbol bajo el modelo de compra 1
siembra 1
una idea simple pero había que hacerla
bien y colaborando siempre es mejor así
encontramos una organización en cusco
que nos ayudó a diseñar un programa para
que pudiéramos ayudarles a comunidades a
sembrar árboles árboles nativos en el
tiempo se convirtieran en madera
sostenible y certificada
así tendrían un ingreso adicional y eso
significaría que por cada árbol talado
siempre habría unos sembrados
sabemos que hay límites y que hay
muchísimo por hacer
y nosotros estamos trabajando muy duro
muy muy duro y a la fecha hemos logrado
abrir a 10 mil 793 niños en más de 100
comunidades hemos sembrado cerca de
6.000 árboles hemos reciclado más de
80.000 botellas plásticas de 2 litros le
hemos dado trabajo a los internos y
estamos trabajando en un programa para
llevar agua potable a escuelas
altoandinas también
mi hermano y aun hace un tiempo me dijo
de que de lo único que somos dueños de
nuestra energía hoy puedo decir que la
hemos echado a andar ahí desde nuestro
metro cuadrado
hemos sido agentes de cambio yo me
siento súper orgulloso de pertenecer a
un proyecto que utiliza la fuerza
empresarial como una herramienta de
impacto para generar cambios reales que
pone sobre la mesa la opción de consumir
de manera responsable y consecuente
hace años en la facultad escuché renzo
piano un gran maestro arquitecto decir
que él se sentía satisfecho de mirar
atrás y sentirse orgulloso no solo de
las obras que había hecho sino de lo que
estaba dejando desde ese día es lo que
yo ando buscando y espero en el futuro
poder mirar atrás y decir que ayude a
que este fuera un mejor lugar
de mostrarle a mis hijos la
responsabilidad de consumir de manera
consecuente y que uno solo puede ser el
cambio gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]